are you able to uh oh you're pretty open
uh with your feelings do you pretty much
will you feel something you don't hold
it in for a month and then go hey
remember last month when you said what
what
last month i'm a dude i can't remember
what i had for break
you know what i mean do you tend to like
bring things up like you know what this
happened i just want to bring it up it
bothered me a little bit are you able to
do that with anybody
yeah now i think now i am if we had had
this conversation when i was 21
i would have said no i can't i have no
idea
how to talk about my feelings talk about
what's bothering me
even acknowledge that something is
bothering me then that i have
a right to have something bother me but
now
i feel fairly capable most of the time
being first of all i can acknowledge
when i'm feeling something i can see
when i'm making something up
i can address it so it's made a big
difference in my life in my
relationships i imagine i'm much easier
to be around now
you've always been easy to be around
krista
have you experienced any loss thus far
in life
in 37 years any loss that's been kind of
like that you sort of
something that you know because for me i
think it's been i've had two losses in
48 years which i'm lucky because people
have
i mean i have a friend ethan who i love
who lost his parents at a very young age
and it breaks my heart
and you can just see the love he still
has for them and
um you know loss is something that like
uh you know can be devastating and how
you deal with it and how it makes you
stronger
and have you had to deal with any of
that well
i i mean my grandparents have all passed
away but
i think like my grandmother that i was
closest to
she died when i was quite young um
and it had a big impact on my life but i
was six
you know um very different
and as as an adult
like when it comes to the finality of
loss
in regards to like death for instance i
i
haven't i haven't had anyone very very
close to me
pass in a way that was traumatic for me
um
but i mean i've dealt with loss in less
permanent ways
um relationships you know yeah
lots of relationships like multiple
friendships that have
proven to be you know
really destructive in my life um
so things like that i've had to face and
and i think it's certainly
given me a more deep experience of life
yeah and it's funny because the
relationships
you know you think of death when you
think of life but a relationship it is
or
you know it feels like death sometimes i
i've had those feelings in my stomach
where i'm like oh my gosh i can't
function because of
of this uh of a breakup or whatever and
it's like you know that's
it's incredible it can be incredibly
painful something that you have to keep
in check and you know
i think it is painful it's just a
different kind of
again i haven't had anyone really close
to me past that isn't you know a
grandparent
but the loss of death i think is very
different i mean you could speak to that
more than i
could than the loss of relationship that
you're grappling with different things
sure